foreign
Waters of the Mediterranean lie
Treasures of ancient empires
relics of their bloody wars
and secrets of the seismic forces that
shaped them
lost beneath the waves
until now
imagine if we could empty the oceans
letting the water drain away to reveal
the secrets of the seafood
now we can
using the latest underwater scanning
technology
the Deep oceans
and turning accurate data into 3D images
this time
what apocalyptic disaster triggered the
collapse of Europe's first civilization
[Music]
can an extraordinary two and a half
thousand-year-old shipwreck unlock the
secrets of Ancient Greece how did these
deadly objects turn ancient Rome into a
superpower and why does the Sin City of
the Roman Empire lie abandoned beneath
the waves
foreign
people call it the Middle Sea the center
of the Known World the Egyptians Greeks
and Romans build Mighty civilizations
upon its Shores
Empires battle for Supremacy across its
Waters
cities Grow Rich and Powerful through
trade the Mediterranean becomes a super
highway connecting cultures that will
shape the modern world
but only by draining the sea can we
reveal its biggest and most terrifying
Secret
what happened on this spectacular Greek
Island
to Doom an entire civilization
you must have thought this was it the
end of the world
three thousand six hundred years ago
fifteen centuries before the Roman
Empire a mysterious people dominate the
Mediterranean
call them the Minoans
their home is on Crete
here they build magnificent temples and
palaces and decorate them with stunning
frescoes
celebrating their love of life and of
nature
foreign
[Music]
but there's a darker side too
the minoan Royal Palace at nusks is said
to contain a labyrinth home to the
Minotaur
a fearsome creature part man part bull
with a terrible appetite for human flesh
but apart from a grisly myth much about
the minoan world Still Remains a mystery
we can't decipher their language we only
have their archaeological remains but
what that tells us I think is that they
were extremely imaginative they were
extremely adventurous and that they
developed a sophisticated hierarchical
society that was capable of producing
elements of art and architecture which
still astounders today
[Music]
historians do know that the Minoans
spread across the Mediterranean trading
olive oil and pottery for gold and Ivory
growing ever richer and more powerful
and then in the 15th century BC their
ancient civilization begins to fade from
the pages of History
for centuries no one knows why
until scientists start to look closely
at the nearby island of Santorini
Santorini it has this very very calm
water
it's almost like it plays with you and
deceives you
looking at this view you would never
imagine how dangerous it once was and
how dangerous it is
the island is famous for its spectacular
Jagged Cliffs which Tower above a
beautiful natural Harbor
but what created them
and can they help explain the downfall
of the Minoans
marine geologist Evie nomikou believes
that crucial Clues May lie deep beneath
Santorini's Tranquil Waters
as I was born in sadorini I wanted to
study the area to reveal their secret
being a marine geologist means that you
are having access to the Mystic world of
the Sith Lord so you can see features
that nobody else can see
she harnesses the latest multi-beam
sonar technology to scan the depths of
the huge Bay
by transforming her data into powerful
computer imagery
it's possible to drain away the Waters
of the Mediterranean
and reveal Santorini's terrifying Secret
the sheer Cliffs Tower a thousand feet
above sea level
and drop a further thousand feet to the
seafood
framing a vast Basin large enough to
hold ten thousand Olympic stadiums
crater
and Santorini itself is the remnant of a
gigantic volcano
but that's not all
on the rim of the crater more evidence
of Santorini's violent past
undiscovered until 1967.
these shattered ruins are all that
remain of a once thriving City
known today as akriteri
it was destroyed when the volcano
erupted and buried under so much Ash
that it remained hidden for three and a
half thousand years it's almost like a
window back in time where you can see
how it was when it was destroyed
and deep in the ruins archaeologists
discover something remarkable
thank you
these Stone steps were not broken by the
Ash and lava from a volcano
they were Shattered by an earthquake
when the earthquake happened everyone
fled their town
but then they came back to start
rebuilding their homes and this is
exactly what we're seeing here
believing the danger over people move
furniture into the streets so they can
start repairing their houses
we're seeing the beds placed outside of
their homes we're seeing these stones
and mud getting ready to be used to
rebuild these homes
but then they are struck by an
apocalypse
the first stage of the eruption is so
powerful that it engulfs our Criterion
and suffocates the whole island in a
thick layer of debris
thank you
and the date of this cataclysmic
eruption
around 1625 BC
the same time as the Minoans begin to
disappear from the pages of History
but how could a single eruption trigger
the collapse of a great civilization
based on an island 70 miles away
until recently most scientists have
focused only on the evidence above
ground
but Evie nomiku believes that once again
the real Clues lie underwater
scientists have been occupied studying
only their own land geology so we are
starting mopping the seafloor in order
to find out the total volume of that big
destructive eruption
heavy heads outside the great crater to
hunt for new evidence on the seabed
what she finds is extraordinary proof of
the sheer scale of this eruption
as the Waters of the Mediterranean
recede still further they reveal wide
Stone Terraces
Fanning out from the mouth of the
volcano
the size of 20-story buildings
[Music]
they point to one cause
they're called pyroclastic flows
torrents of superheated gas and molten
rock
the proclastic floor can cover
everything they travel like a hurricane
they can destroy everything on their
past because of the high temperature up
to 1000 Celsius
pyroclastic flows cool and become solid
ramparts of Rock
around Santorini they stretch for a
staggering 20 miles in every direction
evidence of multiple eruptions lasting
for days
[Music]
by measuring the stone Terraces
scientists calculate that the volcano
throws out 14 cubic miles of debris an
eruption far more powerful than they had
ever imagined
it's one of the biggest volcanic
explosions in the history of the planet
let's try to imagine what this eruption
looked like
if you were sitting somewhere in any of
the neighboring Islands it would have
appeared like the end of the world
at first the volcano blasts out a column
of superheated debris more than 20 miles
high
huge funnel of black ash and Cloud could
have been seen going all the way to the
sky
some of the volcanic plume Falls to
Earth many miles from Santorini
you have been raining pumice on the
surrounding Islands but now the volcano
unleashes its most devastating surprise
and in its path lies creep the center of
the minoan world
70 miles from Santorini the Minoans on
Creek see the soaring column of Ash and
smoke from the erupting volcano
but they have no idea of the disaster to
come the volcano blasts millions of tons
of lava into the sea triggering wave
after wave of powerful tsunamis
when the tsunami arrived in Crete they
were probably taken totally by surprise
imagine seeing this wall of water in
some places 10 meters high advancing in
it must have looked like that this was
the end of the world totally unexpected
the Wrath of the Gods
entire Coastal communities are Swept
Away by waves up to 30 feet tall
sports are destroyed and ships smashed
to pieces
and the gods aren't finished yet
after the eruption and the tsunamis
another disaster is looming clouds of
volcanic ash cast a deadly Paul over the
whole Mediterranean
dramatically cooling the Earth
there were a series of effects from the
eruption that together fatally weakened
the minoan civilization
a tsunami event a Divine event the
destabilization of their economy
failure of harvests over several years
that was the moment when minoan
civilization started to die
without their ports and ships the
Minoans lose their Mastery over the
Mediterranean
Invaders challenge their power
and as the sun sets on the collapsing
minoan civilization new powers arise
500 miles from Crete just off the coast
of Cyprus the draining Waters of the
Mediterranean reveal a remarkable
Discovery almost two and a half thousand
years old
what can it tell us about the lives the
power and the pleasures of the ancient
Greeks
in the centuries after the fall of the
Minoans the city-states of Greece
produce dazzling art and architecture
forging ideas in mathematics democracy
and theater that still shape our world
the Greeks take to the sea in their
wooden sailing ships risking their lives
to explore colonize and trade with each
other
hundreds of boats shuttle across the
Mediterranean linking settlements in
Africa Asia and Europe they are the
lifeblood of Greek civilization
but these ships are a mystery only a few
remnants have survived to offer a
glimpse into how they worked and what
they carry
until now
a shipwreck recently discovered in the
Seas off Cyprus is helping to bring this
Lost World back to life
[Music]
archaeologist Stella domestica and her
team are unlocking the Rex secrets
[Music]
where did it come from
what was it carrying
and why did it sink
it's pretty deep so it takes a while
when you're diving before you can see
the sea bottom
it looks all very Higgly pickledy it
looks like well
someone's dropped a whole load of
garbage in the ocean
but this apparent chaos is packed with
clues about the Lost World of the
ancient Greeks
this is really fantastic for an
artologist
exploring such a deep and complex sight
is challenging
[Music]
diving at 45 meters has several
constraints and time is one of them
the maximum we can stay per day is 20
minutes
it's almost impossible to work
effectively at such depths
so the team explores the site using a
technique called photogrammetry taking
hundreds of pictures of the wreck from
different angles
so instead of
trying to make decisions at 45 meters
where your brain doesn't work properly
taking the pictures allows us to have
the luxury of diving through the screen
of our computer as long as we want it
using the unique photogrammetry data
possible for the first time to drain the
Mediterranean
allowing sunshine to illuminate a sight
that's been in darkness for two and a
half thousand years
the debris lies in the shape of a ship
much of the Timber Hull has rotted away
leaving only its ancient cargo
hundreds of earthenware jars known as
amphery piled neatly on top of each
other
many of them still intact
I'm free look very odd they look very
ungainly and not very well designed to
be storage jars or certainly container
jars on a sea vessel but they are a
design that's involved over centuries
and actually if you stack them all
really neatly together they do all make
sense
and they were the way that you
transported things around the ancient
world
M3 like this give the archaeologists
some vital Clues
their distinctive shape varies depending
on where and when they were made
[Music]
this one dates from the 4th Century BC
and comes from the Greek island of kiosk
500 miles from the wreck site
so what was in it
although the amphery are all now empty
they offer intriguing clues about what
they once contained in this case we have
the opportunity to see evidence
this dark coating inside the infora we
have to imagine that it was all over the
inside walls and it was peach or resin
so it was a kind of sealant to make this
walls waterproof so we are sure that
these are key and wine containers
wine from the island of kiosk is highly
prized throughout the ancient
Mediterranean
the wrecked ship is loaded with the
equivalent of more than 10 000 modern
sized bottles a hugely valuable cargo
and a telling insight into the ancient
Greek trade in luxury goods
the Greeks loved their wine
this little rack of Cyprus is the tip of
the iceberg of the wine trade it was an
absolutely fundamental part of their
society and of all their cultural
experiences whether that be religious or
whether it be letting their hair down
and having really good time
the greatest thing about ancient Greeks
is their love for life they like to talk
to think to discuss to drink to party
there was a great profit to be made in
making sure that the rich around the
Mediterranean world had a good supply of
very good wine to drink
wine and other luxury items makes good
money for the Greek city-states
but their ships carry an even more
precious cargo as they Traverse the
Mediterranean and Beyond
from Egypt to Southern France
they spread Greek ideas and culture that
influence Western Civilization to the
present day
but this cargo never reaches its
destination
one of the most important questions that
we ask in shipwreck archeology is why
this ship sunk
the biggest clue is the shape of the
debris
the way that the jars lie grouped
together rather than scattered about
proves that the vessel didn't capsize
so what did happen
the ships in Antiquity were open decked
the hold was not covered with a deck so
when the waves were very high or we have
a storm then the water was coming in
the ship is most likely overwhelmed by a
wave
pulled down by the weight of all the
expensive wine to a watery grave
[Music]
as the Waters of the Mediterranean
continue to drain away
they uncover unique evidence of a
Titanic clash between two ancient
superpowers
this is the site of a battle that would
change the course of history
when they saw the Romans in front of
them they had one of these oh no moments
what can these bizarre objects on the
seabed tell us about the merciless rise
of the Romans
the third Century BC Rome already
controls Mainland Italy and has
Ambitions to expand across the whole
Mediterranean but its Navy is weak Rome
was known as being a terrestrial power
not a maritime power it was not known
for fighting sea battles but they were
set on a militaristic path of Maritime
control
this brings them into conflict with
another superpower of the Mediterranean
the carthaginians
the carthaginians were great Traders
great seafarers controlling most of the
West and Central Mediterranean and it
was that fact that brought them into
conflict with Rome
Carthage from its position on the North
coast of Africa commands the most
powerful navy in the region
to challenge Carthage Rome must first
learn a new kind of Naval Warfare
so begins a Titanic struggle that will
last for more than a hundred years
the winner will dominate the
Mediterranean for the next seven
centuries
its first truly decisive encounter
happens somewhere off the west coast of
Sicily
near the egadi islands
here according to ancient historian
polybius the mighty navies of Rome and
Carthage go head to head in an epic
battle
he describes the Clash of two huge
fleets involving 400 ships and at least
a hundred thousand men
turning the Waters of the Mediterranean
blood red
but polybius writes his history at least
half a century after the battle
and for a Roman audience so how reliable
is his account
however huge this battle may have been
no one has ever been able to find any
trace of it
taking the description uh from an
ancient historian and actually pointing
to the exact place on the surface of the
globe where the battle took place is
extremely difficult
Bill Murray and a team of marine
archaeologists are on the trail of some
extraordinary fines reported by local
fishermen
but the area they need to survey is huge
many miles across
so first they sonar scan the seabed
then they launch a remotely operated
vehicle to investigate the fines
as you're watching the live feed of the
video from the ROV and it's going across
the sea floor the the shape suddenly pop
into view and it's incredibly
distinctive so there's a great moment of
excitement as these objects are first
seen
they discover a truly astonishing shape
300 feet down yeah
these are the rarest artifacts we have
from antiquity
so what is it
using the data gathered by the
Expedition it's possible to pull the
plug on the Mediterranean emptying the
waters from around the coast of Sicily
the mysterious object on the seabed
comes clearly into view it's three feet
wide and made of metal its Jagged edges
suggest a deadly purpose so these are
bronze battering ramps
they would have been attached to the the
front of a ship
and this was the main method of
attacking and destroying ships in
Antiquity
Rams are the super weapons of ancient
Naval Warfare
the large vertical fin is like a
splitting ax
and the horizontal fins are like blades
to slice through an enemy ship's Timbers
cannon fire there were no kind of guns
in Ally Pirates of the Caribbean or
anything like that the only way to take
down an enemy ship was to smash a
massive hole in the middle of it and let
it sink to the bottom and the only way
of doing that was to Ram it
a closer look reveals that this Ram is
battle damaged its metal edges broken
and distorted by a violent Collision
in one episode we're told that the men
up in a forward Tower were literally
catapulted out of the Tower and into the
sea after a ram strike
and we're told that it was an effective
Ram strike because as the ancient author
wrote bronze hit bronze
and this isn't the only Discovery
Based on data from the survey
draining away more of the Mediterranean
reveals a remarkable pattern
10 more Rams scattered across two square
miles
more than enough to convince historians
that an important naval battle took
place here
[Music]
but is it the legendary Battle of the
eggerty islands described by polybius
unlikely piece of evidence May hold the
answer
a single M for a storage jar found near
one of the Rams
by analyzing its shape
archaeologists can narrow down when and
where it was made
it's like finding a black box recorder
amphra is carthaginian and dates to the
3rd Century BC the same period as the
battle of the egadi islands
the historian polybius describes how the
carthaginians are carrying supplies for
their soldiers in Sicily
could this Emperor be part of that cargo
plan was to cross to mount eriche
unobserved by the enemy and offload the
stores then take on the soldiers in the
lightened ships and engage the enemy
but the carthaginians never make it
compelling evidence from the drained
seabed now indicates this is where it
all happened a number of rams line up
and give us a bearing that makes some
sense
and that's fascinating that is exciting
the words of an ancient historian and
the evidence of modern technology both
point to the same conclusion this is the
site of the battle of the eggerty
islands
it was an important enough event for the
Romans that they remembered the date it
was actually written down in a calendar
somewhere and we know that it occurred
on 10 March 241 BC
this is not your typical naval battle
where both sides prepare this was a
battle of opportunity
still Laden with supplies head for sure
believing the coast is clear
but the Romans keep dozens of their
ships hidden behind one of the islands
it's a huge ambush
the Lookouts spied The carthaginian
Ships coming in and as the carthaginians
saw the Romans in front of them they had
one of these oh no moments
so we're talking about tens of thousands
of men on board these ships and they
would have lined up across from each
other in lines of battle headed toward
each other at a great rate and smashed
into each other Head to Head
polybius describes what happened next
before long they were defeated
50 of the carthaginian ships were sunk
and 70 captured with their Crews while
the prisoners numbered almost 10 000.
another discovery on the seabed is a
stark reminder that this epic Victory
came at a high price in human life
this is the last resting place of
thousands of brave men
[Music]
and it has been judged so important that
its exact location must remain secret
there's nothing else really like this
it's the first ancient battle site
that's ever been discovered it's just an
incredible debris field
for the battle of the gadions was the
turning point when Roman Fleet managed
to absolutely trounce a carthagini
inflatency
this was the defining battle where Rome
went from a regional power to a
superpower
[Music]
struggle between Rome and Carthage would
last for another century
but Victory here set Rome on a path to
shaping the destiny of Europe for the
next 700 years
as the last of its water runs away the
Mediterranean reveals a final seat
what can draining the Bay of Naples
teach us about the glory and the
decadence of the Roman Empire
two thousand years ago Rome has grown
far beyond its Italian Homeland
its Legions control a vast area from
North Africa to Northern Europe
from Spain to the Black Sea
and the Roman Navy dominates the
Mediterranean from its Port next to the
city of bayai
in the shadow of Mighty Vesuvius
bayai earns a reputation as the Sin City
of ancient Rome it's famous for
debauchery and excess
but what really went on in this Seaside
party town and why does so much of it
lie abandoned beneath the waves
now Marine archaeologist John Henderson
is exploring the secrets of this Sunken
City
starting with the huge Harbor walls that
once surrounded the city's port
[Music]
incredible Engineers you can still see
the artificial construction of this very
clearly you can see the brickwork
overlapping bricks
amazing
[Music]
beyond the port walls lie magnificent
Villas where Roman emperors host lavish
parties
look at this this is a mosaic floor of
one of the bath houses
looks like it was just done yesterday
it's phenomenal
absolutely amazing
[Music]
this is called an unfair
It's actually an elaborate dining room
for the emperor Claudius you can imagine
people eating food surrounded by these
water nymphs it was built to entertain
the emperor's most honored guests
[Music]
but one of the things I'm interested in
is actually the scale of the site much
of the focus has been on the resort area
by eye itself but on the margins of the
site there are constantly new areas
coming up
that's it slow down
there's a lot down there
so why did the Romans lavish so much
wealth on building a pleasure City here
the Romans came to buy eye because of
the lovely maritime climate and the
thermal Springs
but bayai was also a very important port
it's a natural Port it's one of the best
ports on the western coast of Italy at
the time
wealth brought pleasure and excess to
this Las Vegas of the Roman world
there were parties there was drinking it
was a place to get prostitutes and
writers at the time referred to as a
harbor of Vice or a Vortex of luxury
the famous Roman philosopher Seneca is
appalled by what he finds
by eye is a place to be avoided
people wandering drunk along the beach
the riotous reveling of sailing parties
the Lakes noisy with singing
but time is running out for this party
town
[Music]
gradually many of its most impressive
public buildings and private Villas are
lost beneath the waves
what happened
based on detailed sonar scanning
draining away the Mediterranean begins
to reveal the real story of the rise and
fall of Bion
it exposes how much of the city fell
under the waves
430 Acres of streets shops warehouses
and luxury villas
draining beyond the town uncovers the
reason
an extraordinary landscape shaped by
powerful underground forces
the whole town
sits inside the shallow Crater of a
giant volcano
you hear about Naples people talk about
Vesuvius they don't seem to realize that
the whole Western Bay of Naples itself
is a massive volcano
we're actually standing in a volcano now
the people of bayai may not understand
the unpredictable forces stirring
beneath them
and we know we're sat on a volcano
but it's not your normal volcano it's
this much larger and much more complex
volcanic system
there is remarkable evidence of its
Restless power three miles away across
the bay in the temple of serapis
foreign
[Music]
ruins that you can see what's going on
you have to look closely though if you
look up at the column behind me you'll
see in the middle part it's got this
strange texture to it lots and lots of
holes in it
there's even bits of shell on this this
is a stone boring Marine mollusk that
tells me that this stuff has been under
the sea
time enough for those mollusks to get to
grips with the columns but look now
these columns are in place and look
where those marker Horizons are now
that's like a tide on the side of a bath
telling you where the sea level was so
we know that this has been dropped under
the sea and it's now risen above
can draining the Waters of the bay even
further explain why this ancient
landscape is constantly rising and
falling
and finally show why the Romans lost
their Sin City
by eye once a major Roman poor
lies half submerged
amid a volcanic landscape
area beneath the waves
waves and he finds a Telltale sign of
the power at work here
you really get a sense here the power
that's underneath
waiting to bust out
hot water piling out of the ground under
the sea
I've never seen anything like this
underwater vents are superheated by
molten rock from the volcano below
evidence that the forces stirring under
Bay Eye are highly active
locals call the area can't be flegri the
fields of Fire
now for the first time draining the
water from the entire Bay
exposes an extraordinary sight
24 separate volcanoes nesting inside the
crater
spans an incredible 38 square miles
a geologist here have been mapping deep
inside the Earth itself
[Music]
now draining not only the Mediterranean
but looking deep into the layers of rock
below it
reveals a Fantastical sight
giant cauldrons of superheated molten
rock known as magma chambers that slowly
empty and fill over centuries
evidence that this huge volcanic system
is still very much alive
basically you've got magma chamber
sitting under the sea which operate
almost like Bellows when they fill full
of lava the ground goes up and then when
they empty again the ground goes down
and this process is going on constantly
it's as if the land within the Conti
flegri crater itself
is breathing
feel like you're standing on some Giants
you feel minute compared to the giant
tectonic forces that are creating the
world around you the damage caused by
these breathing chambers of magma
coincides with the decline of the Roman
Empire
as part of the city slides beneath the
Mediterranean the population shrinks and
the party's end
Sin City
is no more
today the scientists studying the
landscape here believe that pressures in
the magma Chambers are increasing once
again and that could have catastrophic
consequences for the millions of people
living close by
we know it's an active system so one of
the interesting problems we have with
something the size of campyflagray is is
it going to erupt big or is it going to
erupt small
[Music]
big could me
very big
in ad79 nearby Vesuvius erupts
it destroys the city of Pompeii
thousands of people burned to death or
choke on volcanic ash
[Music]
but scientists know the volcanic system
feeding the fields of fire is far larger
and far more powerful than Vesuvius
and with so many people living nearby
it's vital to keep a close eye on the
breathing giant beneath them
[Music]
even more critical that we monitor
volcanoes like this and that's because
we're verging on the side of what we
call a super volcano
changes in the ground level or its
temperature could be a vital warning
sign that the Unstoppable forces of
nature are about to turn
ugly
if we had an eruption where these
multiple craters evacuated it would be
devastating
it would essentially flatten this area
the eruption could be almost 10 times
more powerful than the one at Santorini
that shattered the minoan world
vast amounts of volcanic material would
be ejected into the atmosphere
blocking out the sunlight
global temperatures would plummet with
devastating consequences
new scanning technology reveals
remarkable evidence lying hidden beneath
the Waters of the Mediterranean the raw
forces of nature still shaping this
volcanic landscape
Priceless evidence of the trade that
drove the ancient world
and an epic battle
that changed the course of history
[Music]